thanks to nebula and curiositystream for
sponsoring this video an extended
version of this video is available right
now on nebula
ah Kyoto seat of the Japanese government
for 11 centuries famous for its 2000
temples and shrines for its Rock Gardens
and for one of the most important but
flawed International treaties of all
time in 1997 193 countries signed the
Kyoto Protocol formally agreeing that
scientific evidence indicated global
warming was taking place due to human
emission of greenhouse gases and that we
should do something to limit those
emissions this was hugely significant it
was the first time that countries agreed
to do something about lowering
greenhouse gas emissions the protocol
tried to be clever about how they did
this while recognizing that more work
was required in the future it only
required action from developed countries
and required more action from the more
polluting countries though shared the
load between all wealthy Nations one way
that the Kyoto Protocol attempted to
accomplish this was through the idea of
emissions trading this is pretty simple
each country is given a certain number
of carbon credits with each credit
allowing that country to emit one tonne
of carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
now if a country wants to emit more
carbon into the atmosphere than it has
credits for it can buy credits from
other countries which now can emit less
carbon but have more money this means
that if a country wants to emit lots of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere they
effectively have to pay a charge to do
so with that money going to countries
which have a lower impact on the
environment so there's an incentive for
countries to lower their emissions
pretty clever this was a market-based
solution inspired by similar one used to
limit sulfur dioxide emissions in the
USA trying to combat acid rain which it
did very effectively in fact America
made the inclusion of this emissions
trading Market a deal breaker in the
Kyoto Protocol refusing to sign unless
it was included they got their way and
then of course refused to ratify the
treaty meaning that they didn't have to
abide by the rule they insisted on for a
everyone else to be more specific there
were three components to this trading
there was the basic emissions trading
that I just described but also the CDM
the clean development mechanism where
rich countries would pay developing
countries to undertake projects that
would keep their emissions low investing
in renewable energy things like that
there was also the joint implementation
scheme where rich countries would
collaborate together to jointly try and
keep their emissions low it sounds
pretty comprehensive using the power of
Market forces to tackle climate change
pad on covers all the eventualities rich
countries developing countries
collaboration
climate change complete it mate however
it turned out this Market approach was
pretty flawed it succeeded in bringing
down emissions a bit but not effectively
and in fact the markets created under
the Kirito protocol didn't survive very
long at all the protocol came into force
in 2008 and by 2012 the clean
development mechanism the CDM saw a
complete market crash as did The Joint
implementation scheme it turned out that
there were a number of loopholes
exploits if you will in these market
trading mechanisms and companies
operating in countries that signed up to
the Kyoto Protocol found these very
quickly now I don't know a lot about
exploits
but I do happen to know someone who does
hello ladies and gentlemen I'm the
smithing Brit and today we're talking
about some absolutely game breaking
exploits and of course everyone's
favorite International treaty the Kyoto
Protocol this is one of my favorite
International treaties to absolutely
break and believe me well the intention
of the treaty was definitely to limit
greenhouse gas emissions we're going to
talk about some extra spicy loopholes
that basically reward the exact opposite
Behavior so get yourself a cup of tea
smash that subscribe button and if
you're feeling particularly Majestic you
can even like Simon's video now firstly
let's talk about the hydrofluorocarbons
or to you and me hfcs these are a happy
family of chemicals mostly used to
replace CFCs another family of chemicals
don't worry it's all sciency but I'm
sure you're all smart enough to
understand now these chemicals are
pretty unique because sadly they have an
unfortunate side effect of destroying
the ozone layer which we actually need
to survive Now hfc 23 is an extremely
potent greenhouse gas eleven thousand
times more powerful than CO2 and of
course under the Kyoto Protocol you can
receive carbon credits for destroying it
so if you were to say artificially
create the gas only to then destroy it
you can effectively Farm infinite carbon
credits very spicy now how do you create
hsc23 URS well this is the best part
because you can actually create it as a
side product of producing
hcfc22 what's that oh nothing very
interesting it's another chemical that's
a minor greenhouse gas but it also
destroys the ozone layer so just to be
clear in one easy step you can increase
the market demand for hfc gases and then
of course whilst trying to protect a
dwindling ozone layer and you can also
get paid by International governments to
destroy the side products which happens
to be a hfc gas as well and guess what
cheeky buggers did this all over the
world oh they are so cheeky and they do
love destroying the environment but
seriously did they not consult anyone
about this I mean anyone can see that
there's an X exploiting this you're
rewarding people for producing
greenhouse gases and then rewarding them
for destroying it they're going to
create an infinite Loop to make money
come on guys it's not difficult but
that's just one example of an exploit
this next one is exceedingly spicy and
it all uses nitrous oxide this is
another greenhouse gas of course 300
times more dangerous than carbon dioxide
and under Kyoto you can claim hundreds
of carbon credits by eliminating one
tonne of nitrous oxide now of course
hundreds of carbon credits now I like
the smell of all of that money in South
Korea example rhodia invested 15 million
dollars in equipment that destroys
nitrous oxide but that investment
produced 1 billion in carbon credits now
that's far more than should have been
possible and how do they do this how do
they convert 15 million into 1 billion
well it's very simple firstly Rodeo
received carbon credits for destroying
the nitrous oxide great job Goldstar
you're saving the planet so take some
money however rhodia is a company based
in Europe and rhodier is a company that
voluntary chose to destroy nitrous oxide
and even spend money on on equipment to
do so as such because of a fantastic
legal loophole the carbon credits it
received under the CDM fell outside of
the EU emissions trading scheme as far
as the EU Market was concerned carbon
credits were just appearing out of thin
air into rodia's account and Rodier of
course could do what all the other
companies do and sell those carbon
credits on the market that meant rodie
was being paid to destroy nitrous oxide
under the CDM and paid to sell its
carbon credits on a different Market in
the EU now that is totally and utterly
broken it's effectively double counting
any emissions reductions and then of
course allowing the selling of carbon
credits to other companies in the EU
Market but these credits have come from
literally nowhere companies buying them
on in the EU Market were doing so in
order to of course offset their own
emissions those emission reductions
weren't real it's like me buying a get
out of jail free card from my friend for
dumping oil in the sea whilst my friend
owns an oil out of the sea pumping
company which is located really really
far away oh and guess what they've got a
lot of get out of jail free cards so I'm
going to keep pouring oil into the ocean
so by doing this Rudy was being paid to
destroy emissions in Korea and then
being paid again to allow emissions in
Europe it's absolutely crazy I could go
on and carbon trading is literally
ridden with legal loopholes and just
companies that are exploiting the ever
living hell out of it and I know it
sounds crazy ladies and gentlemen but
it's almost like capitalism doesn't have
the environment's best interests at
heart oh dear instead it has money at
heart and I love money and that's why
I'm announcing that spifco is setting up
its own carbon neutral company where
we're going to be pumping deadly nitrous
oxide out of the environment and dumping
it in France that'll serve you right
Frenchies anyway time to go clearly my
ex-boy powers are too great to use here
so it's naturally back to making Simon
cry in SIV again and trust me it's not
difficult anyway cheerio
okay maybe he's right quite apart from
all of these exploits and there are a
lot of them there is literally an entire
Interpol document on the loopholes that
companies found and the colonial
overtones of developed countries
Outsourcing the hard work to developing
countries in a system that the developed
countries designed themselves
and there are a lot of those too the
emissions training scheme fell apart
because it was never the right tool for
this task it had previously seen success
in curving sulfur Dark Side emissions in
the USA limiting acid rain but that's an
entirely different kettle of fish to
limiting carbon emissions generating
sulfur dioxide is not a fundamental
prerequisite for our modern standard of
living like generating carbon emissions
is also the scale of the problem is
completely different acid rain is a
serious problem but climate change is
potentially
civilization ending and this was raised
at the negotiation table in Kyoto with
critics arguing that in this context an
emissions training scheme was like
abandoning climate change to the law of
the Jungle it was just too important to
do that but thanks to the insistence of
American delegates at Kyoto with America
going on to Nether actually ratify the
treaty we ended up with a emissions
trading scheme a market-based solution
because remember member capitalism
solves everything but the fact is that
capitalist markets have one goal
maximize profits that's it and so
companies will exploit any loopholes in
the market to maximize their profits it
doesn't matter if the market was created
for environmental reasons if profits can
be maximized at the expense of the
environment they will be this was so
widespread that one estimate states that
only two percent of CDM projects had a
high likelihood of actually reducing
emissions many schemes ended up
increasing carbon emissions overall
through funneling money to extractive
Industries such as coal mining and even
directly to coal-fired power plants if
they just claimed their technology was
the most efficient type which is a bit
like giving out awards for best films
and giving one to Transformers because
it's the best in the Transformers series
but a flawed solution is still better
than no solution at all right well yes
the Kyoto protocol's emissions trading
scheme did reduce greenhouse gas
emissions a bit but that's ignoring the
fact that there were other better
solutions that almost certainly would
have resulted in a greater reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions if you want to
implement a global climate solution that
uses Market forces to drive down carbon
emissions then Implement a carbon tax a
set price for every ton of carbon that's
emitted such that products or services
that take more carbon emissions to
produce than others are more expensive
and the price of carbon gets higher
every year over time the products that
take the least carbon to produce will be
chosen by consumers and Emissions will
fall that is a topic for a whole other
video and does of course have its own
problems but in my opinion and I think
it would be safe to say the opinion of
the majority of environmental economists
a carbon tax would have been far
preferable to the emissions trading
scheme implemented by the Kyoto Protocol
thanks America the lesson here is that
we still need to lower Global greenhouse
gas emissions and doing so will require
new Solutions simply rehashing solutions
from previous environmental problems
isn't good enough it won't work because
we've never faced an issue of this scale
of this complexity before it can be done
but as we've seen at least on a global
scale carbon emissions trading is not
the way to do this that being said there
is one very significant carbon emissions
Market that has arguably been a success
the European Union emissions trading
scheme operational for the past 15 years
the EU ETS has been far more positively
received by economists and
environmentalists than the global market
under the Kyoto Protocol but why why is
the EU ETS viewed differently well I
talk about this in a coder to this video
over on nebula both Smith and myself are
part of the large team of creators
behind nebula a streaming service
designed to be the expansion pack for
the smart part of YouTube how is it an
expansion pack well it features extra
content such as the extra parts of this
video entirely exclusive content such as
my recent video on the carbon footprint
of noted streaming site horn Pub and
best of all it's completely ad free you
pay a small subscription fee and get to
watch the part of YouTube that you
already watch but in high quality early
and with no adverts at all but wait
there's more we've partnered up with
curiositystream the home of the best
documentaries on the internet with a
deal if you sign up to curiositystream
say to watch miniverse Chris Hadfield
driving across our solar system scaled
down to the continental United States
with some guests then you get access to
nebula for free so how much does it cost
to get access to not one but two of the
best streaming websites on the internet
five dollars a month nope just
14.79 a year that's just over one dollar
twenty cents a month frankly this is far
too good a deal to pass up on so make
sure that you go to curiositystream.com
Simon Clark Linked In the description
below to sign up upgrade your viewing
experience and directly support the
educational content on this channel
thank you to curiositystream and to
nebula for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching this
video I hope that you enjoyed it I know
that I certainly had a whale of a time
working with my friend spiff on a video
I don't think anyone's made this kind of
content before I'll be the first to
admit that I am not an economist I am an
atmospheric dynamicist so I hope you'll
forgive me if I made any errors in this
video I tried my best to sum up the
literature on the subject to a lay
audience that said if you do have
opinions on the video please do let me
know down there in the comments I'm
particularly welcome opinions from
people who know a lot about
environmental economics and could
further this conversation if you did
enjoy the video then please do pop it a
like you can subscribe to the channel if
you'd like to see more videos like this
and if you haven't heard of Smith before
then um yeah check him out he'll be one
of the links up here along with some
other recommended viewing
if you haven't met him before you're in
for a wild ride thank you again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one